-Ladies and gentlemen,
it's time for "Screen Grabs."
Here we go.
-♪ Makes me want
to screen grab ♪
-These are some weird,
funny things that you guys
found on the Internet, or took
a picture of in real life,
then sent in to us.
Okay, this first screen grab
was sent in by Steve Frost,
in Boulder, Colorado.
He was doing
some grocery shopping
on Walmart's website, okay?
And he spotted this deal.
Look at this.
Pork chops for only $23,979.39.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-You're telling me
inflation isn't real?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This next one was sent in
by Ramon Cortez,
in San Antonio, Texas.
He was on Hulu looking for
a movie to watch, okay?
And spotted "Boyz n the Hood."
That's right.
They had a great --
[ Laughter ]
Amazing cast.
-Amazing cast.
-Thank you for being a friend.
-Yeah.
-This next one
was sent in by Mary Morgan,
in Anchorage, Alaska.
She was shopping for
a diaper bag on Amazon, right?
And she found a great one.
This is a cool diaper bag,
right?
But this is real.
We didn't mock this up.
Can we look
at the picture underneath?
It's a baby...
[ Laughter ]
It's a baby
doing a one-handed push-up...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Getting ready
for a cage match or something.
[ Laughter ]
-It's just bizarre.
-One-handed push-up.
-Next screen grab was sent in
by Catherine Alexander,
in Seattle, Washington.
She ordered some groceries
on Amazon Fresh, okay?
Yeah, which is great.
And she checked
to see how close it was.
Look, she got milk,
cream cheese, a cucumber there.
Down here, it shows you
where the driver is.
Driver's in Africa.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
That's never good.
-"We'll be there in a couple --"
-"We'll get there."
-"Don't track me.
Do me a favor --
don't track the food.
We'll get there."
-"Don't rush me."
-"Don't worry about it.
6The milk will be cheese
by the time it's there," yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next screen grab was sent in
by George Howard,
in Birmingham, Alabama,
who was filling out
some questions online
before his doctor's visit
and came across --
This is a real question
on the questionnaire.
It says,
"How many fatal heart attacks
have you had in the past year?"
[ Laughter ]
-Let me think.
-"Fatal?
I'd say maybe two?"
-Fatal?
-Fatal heart attacks.
This next screen grab
was sent in by
Larissa Robinson,
in Meridian, Idaho.
She was looking to get
some grill supplies.
-Oh, great.
-This is great.
So it says here up top,
"Tractor Supply has all
the essentials you need
to keep the grill going."
Grilling season is here.
There it is -- coyote urine.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-That's one way
to end the barbecue.
"I'll take care of it.
I'll take care of this."
-Psssh!
-"Don't worry about it!"
-"Get out, get out!"
-Coyote urine.
[ Both laugh ]
We're down to our last one.
This is from Justin Brown,
in Nashville, Tennessee.
He spotted a photo
of an Italian roadie
for Pink Floyd in the '70s,
and he thought
it looked like me.
Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if I see it.
Uh...
Let me try something.
Hold on.
♪♪
All right, let me see.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right.
That's all the time
we have for "Screen Grabs."
If you have a funny screen grab,
e-mail it to us at
screengrabs@tonightshow.com.
We might put it on the show.